Okay, welcome to today's Zoom call or talk about some questions that came up and one of them is something that I did address on a Zoom call, I don't know, a month ago or so, about some sometimes doctors could use some scare tactics.
So, manipulative medicine, we could say, and I do want to address this because I know that it can affect all of us, some of us more than others.
So, I put together just a little mini presentation on it.
The scare tactic in my mind is when someone uses a practitioner uses your diagnosis to get you to do something that maybe you don't want to do.
And you could say from a medical practitioner standpoint, well, they might say, well, I have to enforce the seriousness of this condition to the patient so that they take this seriously and do what they should do.
But even at that, even at best, to me, that is coming from an extremely arrogant point of view, that A, the doctor is the only one who knows what's the best, what's best for the patient, and B, the patient can't think for themselves, it has to surrender all their will and their power to the doctor in order to be healed.
And if you ever hear that from me using scare tactics, please confront me, and if you're in person, just go ahead and slap me to the face, that would be appropriate, I think.
Because I don't think there's any room for scare tactics or manipulation in the practice of healthcare period.
I think that's the right approach, people are intelligent and when you insult their intelligence by basically saying it's my way, is the only way that's arrogant at very least, and it's really playing God, and there's huge danger in that.
And unfortunately, that's what takes place a lot of the time, especially in the practice of oncology.
You can confront this and give the power back to the patient.
So, I want you to have some tools to be able to confront this, but for this, there's been articles written about this, this is back from 2004, New York Times article about doctors using scare tactics, here's one more recent in 2016, about doctors using scare tactics.
There's one that's pinpointing the cancer treatment centers of America, though we've had patients that have had good results with them, but if they're pinpointing the cancer dreams of America, we know it's been elsewhere.
This doctor, actually, Dr. Richard Young is the doctor who wrote this book, American Health Scare, which is quite interesting. I didn't read the whole book, but I read some excerpts of it.
Here's one little clip from it talking about the mental framework of a lot of people in the practice of medicine is that there is a phrase that's used medical, it's medically necessary.
And that's kind of a manipulative tool that is used to kind of get people to not think for themselves and that the doctor, the pharmaceutical industry, the whole medical industry complex knows what's best for the patient.
And if you don't comply with what's best with the patient, that someone else knows what's best for you, that you are basically a non-compliant individual.
And many times it's posted if you could see what your chart says in some of these clinics, you would be appalled quite honestly if you are one of those non-compliant people.
So this is coming up, not just in the practice of oncology, but certainly a lot of information is coming out with vaccinations and forced vaccinations and medical manipulation of the medical pharmaceutical industry, basically saying that you as a consumer don't have the right to your body anymore that you need to listen to what to the medical pharmaceutical industry is saying.
Quite honestly is offensive at the very least.
Fear based medicine is on the rise and it's something that you as an individual need to confront.
So our part I really believe since I came into practice back in in 1986 is that one of my roles was to be a teacher and to try to re-empower people from this Marcus well-be mentality of the practice of medicine where you just go in and surrender your complete will and your body and your life to a doctor in a sense of trust.
And maybe at one time it was deserved.
I don't know that that is true anymore and when you do surrender your will and your body and everything to a practitioner.
There's a lot of dangers because everybody's coming from a bias you're coming from a bias I'm coming from a bias and certainly a medical practitioner's coming from a bias where are they getting their information from what literature are they reading who's the one who's pushing them in a certain way or not even using an example of the vaccine industry.
I remember years ago I would do lectures against vaccines and that not not that vaccines are all bad but that you should just be aware of what you're ejecting in yourself in a flu vaccine or adult vaccine.
It's certainly in a six pound baby in the normal fetal or newborn vaccine schedules and just trying to make people aware of what is out there that you take your power back and you start asking the right questions.
Where is it I used to people would say well I trust my doctor why would I even question my doctor people and ask that question quite so often anymore but years ago they did.
And my answer was always look at the bias and where you're getting your information from if somebody's coming to you and saying really you should start questioning vaccinations in this case.
Where is my bias I have zero to gain when I tell you that you should start just asking better questions about vaccines and everything to lose because I realize that at least you know large percentage you are going to think that I'm a complete quack by even making this suggestion and certainly it was even worse back then.
Versus a doctor who says absolutely you should get a vaccine whereas what's to gain from them there's financial gain there's there you can say there's acceptance gain they are following what is the standards of care they're going to be able to be accepted by the insurance company.
You're going to look at where the bias is coming from with any information that you're that you're getting you're trying to decipher what is true to that information what does that person who's giving me this information have to gain by giving me this information and you know if I'm going to sift through all the chaos of that information to find the truth look at where that bias is.
So a couple things how do I recognize this scare tactics how do I recognize this pressure sale what i'm getting it from a doctor practitioner for anything not just ecology but for anything you're going in for here's the recommendation you have high blood pressure you're going to take this beta blocker.
How do I recognize a pressure sale by my doctor well i'm just going to give you a few points that just came to mind this afternoon here's one when the doctor doesn't respect any other viewpoint so if if you can't say well is there and what if I just take some supplements what if I change my diet what if I exercise and they don't want to hear any other viewpoint then you start your little spiny senses should go up.
So that's that's one way to know that your spiny senses should go up another when the doctor uses demeaning disparaging tactics when you question their approach we see this a lot so we hear this a lot I should say that patients will come in and say well i even just question what they said and they made me feel like an idiot you know so that's the way to treat another human.
Being regardless of what you're trying to sell it's certainly a bad sales approach but understand it's a good sales approach if you could get a person to surrender their will to you and then then treat them like an idiot if they even question what you say now most doctors are intelligent enough that they could probably talk around your arguments with some.
You know medical terminology that would would belittle you and make you feel foolish because you're not understanding all their terms that they're using you know it kind of pushes you down in your box and when you sense that when you sense that your spirit is kind of being squashed down it's another reason to put up your spiny senses and say maybe this is going on.
Don't understand I am not trying to make every doctor who uses this techniques to be the bad guy I understand this is a learned behavior often so it doesn't mean that they're an evil person or anything like that it can be a learned behavior plus these doctors are going to in services and are getting yelled at literally getting yelled at when they're not getting patients to follow through with standard recommendations.
I think I told you the story before but it's worth repeating we had a patient once that came to us she had breast cancer I think it was this patient but does make a difference she went home she was using her rife she had it set up in her living room and she came back months later for a recheck and she was oh you're going to love this story and I said what's that she was we're getting a kitchen remodeled and the guy remodeling our kitchen looked over the other.
The other day the staff of the other day and saw that I was using my rife machine and said oh you got a rife machine how cool is that and she said I thought that was really odd that this carpenter knew what a rife machine was so he must have been looking at cancer things or something and I said oh you have cancer and started talking with them turns out that this carpenter refinishing their kitchen is actually a medical doctor
and he went on to tell his story that he was going through medical school his dad was a carpenter he did work with his dad helping him refinish kitchens and this was his dad's company and then he went into medicine and he practiced for I think it was 10 to 12 years and he said I just finally had it up to here and I just gave it up and the kicker was when we went into these in services and we used to get yelled at by the pharmaceutical reps
and the last they had it down to a science with with prescribing medications and the last one was we know that you guys are not prescribing right yelling at the doctors because pick a percentage that 67% of the people that you prescribed this medication to should have these side effects that you should then subscribe then prescribe medication B2
and 12% of them should have these side effects that you then should prescribe medication C2 and you only have 47% on medication B and only 6% on medication C so you are not doing your job and he just said that's it this is not the practice of medicine anymore.
this is just totally you know we are just basically tools for the pharmaceutical company to get their percentages up and they got this down to they got it down to this level of science.
I don't know if my story exactly right because this actually happened about six years ago when we were at our other office but I thought that was fascinating how many times doctors hands are tied.
so they might have just gone out of an in service where they got yelled at that X amount of breast cancer patients that came in this month you know certain percentage chose not to get you know the standard people therapy and you're not doing your job as a doctor if you're not getting people to do it here's a way to do it and they give them literally pressure techniques
sales techniques and how to sell chemotherapy to a patient and again I will say if you ever feel that way for me selling you a nutritional product or your plan here well then shame on me because that that's just that that's just not the godly thing to do even if you feel so strongly and you know how strongly I feel about a right machine I feel like nobody should try
to treat cancer without using the right but I also feel like that people should obey God first and if they don't feel led down this pathway then by all means I don't want to have them be my patient so it is it we are to obey God before we obeyed man and when man puts himself any person puts himself in the position of God it uses manipulation tactics to do anything to another person whether it's the same thing
as other person whether it's the cell of a car or the cell of chemotherapy that is not a godly position to be in so little spidey senses should go up when you feel the need do you feel any disparaging tactics you feel like you're being pushed out you feel like you're not being listened to that should make your spidey senses go up another one when your doctor gives you scary timelines or scary outcomes if you do not utilize their approach
to another super common thing this is a really serious cancer misses Smith and if you don't do this you only have an X percent chance of living five years but I know you'll have a much better chance of living this many years
okay the first one who could come up with this stuff in the first place is that is that at all is there any truth to that whatsoever that's why I know from 90% of you call this office and go hey what's your success rate with this cancer
we're not giving you any success rates that is just totally wrong everybody is completely different and these success rates that they talk about are literally pulled out of the air so it is just not correct to do that and it's not correct to use scary highlights to pressure anybody into doing something that's just not the right way to do it if your approach is so good you shouldn't have to sell it
so next what your doctor makes you feel foolish or for even considering another path kind of touched on that before that but anytime you feel belittled or in any way I don't think that's a healthy position to be it and I always tell people you know you always have more time than you think
if you can't walk out of your oncologist's office by saying you know what I want to think about this and pray about this I'll call you back and they can't say all right we're here for you anything you want to do anyway we can help you then I think you probably are the wrong place
and to be honest with you there are plenty of oncologists down the block who will gladly do that because they really do just want to help people and hopefully you're with one of those guys
because there's plenty of people that will say hey I'm here for you whatever you want to do you want to do chemo we'll do chemo you want to only do a few rounds of chemo we'll do that
you know we're here just to help you because we're not God so you know if you don't feel like you're in that place and you don't feel like you can find that that oncologist you know look again because they're all there
really how do you come at this you've got to find yourself a guide not a dictator I hope I'm one of your guides I hope this clinic is one of your guides not your only one by any
stretch of the imagination but you don't want somebody who's going to tell you what to do and I do understand that when you're in you do have a scary diagnosis many times it's our it's a it's a human tendency that we just want to surrender it over
to another person to solve my problem because he's the expert so I'm just going to do whatever the doctor says because that's the way to go they know what's best well maybe maybe not so whatever you surrender your power you want to say it that way over to another person I don't think it's healthy I think we're always supposed to be surrendered our power over to Jesus Christ in him alone and let him guide us what we're supposed to do
and he's not a dictator so when you have that dictatorship relationship with anybody else in this world that is not godly so do not go down that path and then you have to feel empowered
that is that's the key thing I know that's kind of new AG word but I think it's there's a lot of truth to that terminology you have to feel like
like you have control of your health of course you surrendered to god and and of course he is in control but in in a sense that he's giving it back to you that that you're not surrendering it to some outside source that you think has your
you know your ideal in mind because that's not always true but just not I needed to touch on that
it's really interesting we had a patient come in and this is one of these questions stems from that told us oh my gosh she had breast cancer
and she said oh my gosh you need the doctor told me I need to do their chemo and radiation in right away because I have ER, PIA estrogen receptor, progesterone receptor and her two receptor positive cancer
so it's much more serious so I need to do chemo I just actually when she said that I just had to laugh because
I be person of the time it's when you have a triple negative meaning ER negative, PR negative, it hurt to negative
that that is the scary cancer and you need to start chemo right away because this is the more aggressive
breast cancer which which I laughed to that as well because it is not just because you don't show positive
hormone receptors does not mean the cancer is any more aggressive all it means is when you don't show
positive hormone receptors it knocks out about 25% of the drugs that they can offer you so
they get a little nervous and say it's more serious so we need to start chemo right away well it isn't
80 more aggressive per se than any other cancer it just they have less drugs to offer you
and I thought it was so funny when the flip side of this doctor used the same
same scare tactics for somebody who does have ER PR and her two positive oh my gosh it just can't make this stuff up
so you know again it doesn't make your doctor a bad person doesn't you got to understand where they're coming
from but it's time to step out and say I thank you I'll call you when I need you and I thought you
won't do their program but you're going to do it under your you know under your power and certainly
as a believer that you really prayed about it you really have peace about doing that maybe even think
about using a different oncologist that's my take on that okay we're going to open it up for questions
here I will I will let's see hold on I gotta get to the chat I'm unmuting all I did question did come
in before anybody chimes in somebody said I have a doctor who can talk circles around me when it comes
to getting the flu vaccine how do I answer them what I say I prefer not to get vaccinated I really
like this doctor other than that yeah good question you might really love a doctor but they believe
very strongly in something that maybe you don't believe strongly so you know I think there's
value in hearing somebody out but if you don't feel educated enough to get into an argument or I should
say into a debate with somebody I'd suggest you don't get it in debate with somebody what I suggest
you do is you don't get try to get into a debate with any professional like this you just say
I would just say this doctor I love you dearly thank you so much for your opinion but please I
ask that you respect value opinion and to me that would be a relationship killer right there with
anybody in any relationship in respect my opinion I have friends that have completely different spiritual
positions that I have it's like why can't we still be friends so I just don't believe that that
necessarily needs to be a relationship killer or breaker but if they can't respect my position
that they want me to respect their position well that's a relationship breaker so it's um
that's the way I would state that is that thank you for your information while I respect your
position I respect that um your philosophy that you're coming from I just asked that you respect my
position and we can still be friends and we can still have a relationship now if they can't
then that's that's the end of that so you need to find somebody that respects you
okay opening up for questions hopefully that answer that question if you want to elaborate
oh yeah the person who asked that feel free to otherwise any questions for anybody
dr can dr can this is Janet Kissling hello hi I have um I've been going and getting a um lymph drainage
massage yeah and um this particular woman has a lot of other degrees that she's gotten and we were
talking about all the different supplements I'm taking and I noticed in and one of the questions
if someone asked if you if we should continue to take our supplements non-stop and the answer was
no we should take a break from them so no let me elaborate there's some there's some supplements that
can't be good to you know take a weekend or two off a month now some people are you know what I've
talked about this before some people are really good and just regimented and never forgetting to take
their supplements um now those people then those of them is valuable to talk to about pulsing
um now if a person is taking let's say they're taking uh we can boost in um evolve immune or
mushroom product for their cancer should they ever should they ever pulse that my opinion not
necessarily um if they're taking an herbal like an adaptogenic herb for their mood and for their
hormone balance can it be beneficial to pulse that yes so are they taking a vitamin D just for
general vitamin D help do they ever need to pulse that no so the only ones that are really have shown
value to pulse at different times are typically the herbals okay um and then secondly is that
if you are the person that well I'm pretty good at taking it there's few times that I forget to take
them well you are in a sense already pulsing your supplements and what about I'm wondering this um
woman was thinking that I should be um taking a break from my homeopathic remedy that I'm taking
the amalgam okay so homeopath is the one thing that you don't ever have to pulse okay so the only
reason why a person would take a break there's other reasons why you might stop a supplement let's
say you're detoxing too quickly or you know something like that but that's not pulsing okay great thank
you thank you very much sure and if you have specific questions you know no feel free to you know
let me know too uh any specific supplement right so the greens I should come to I should take those
every day and then uh what is I'm taking the uh the other thing I'm taking it's in the powder form
yeah those are food based things I mean you don't ever have to pulse those now again is there
anything wrong with taking a day off or a weekend off of something no there isn't and I don't ever want
anybody to think that uh you have to die if they don't take their supplements today you know right right
we should have that balance right okay that's really good I appreciate that and I just want to say
that I am so blessed to have found you in the clinic and I just I I just am praying for you I'm
praying for the clinic I'm praying for all the other people I just keep watching all the comments and
questions and I just keep praying oh that's great well um you know it was gonna do um uh uh
presentation on prayer because I know one person asked about doing a presentation on
prayer circles but I actually found a video that I did on prayer circles a while back and I posted
it on the Facebook page uh already so for people to make sure you listen to that because I don't know
I'm still showing that when people come here anymore I can't remember but we used to show it to
everybody but they're two days and I don't know if we still do that um yeah but um uh you you did
break up a point that I want to talk to Janet is that um no I know that um uh this might be a
little sticky subject but just in how we pray I want to encourage you believers to think maybe a
little differently than you're thinking though it's when we're in a scary situation we got a cancer
diagnosis something you know um that could drive us to a deeper prayer life a deeper spiritual life
than we had before and praise God for that because that's what could give us depth in our relationship
with praise um but we'd want to move beyond selfish prayers and prayed for my healing and pray
for others and ask God part of your prayer to be Lord who is it you want me to be praying for to
me right I think I mentioned this before and I I still pray for my healing but um that's often
that I pray for yours and uh pray even more so for all of our eyes to be opened up that we
can see and be more like Jesus on a daily basis of that God uses this uh diagnosis that we've been
given to mold us and shape us more to his image because uh it's not just about healing from cancer um
it's about being a different person and glorify God in everyday life that is the real purpose
that we have here so uh you you you said it Janet so I'm just going right off of what you said you
prayed for everybody on that Facebook page you prayed for other people and and praise God if our
diagnosis drives us to that deeper prayer life then we can um have that deeper relationship with
Him so thank you for bringing it up Amen all right other questions Dr. Conor's this is not a question
it's just um something that I have learned since I've had cancer um I've learned to be thankful
thankful for I've learned to be thankful for the cancer but I've learned to
acknowledge God for the things that He has given me that I do not deserve and
made a big difference Amen to that right but what a privilege it is I mean we could have just died
and we hit by a bus right what a privilege it is to um you know get a fatal diagnosis that it makes us
it gives us time to to think about and reassess um a much time we spend you know in selfish acts
and it's just uh it's really a privilege to you know that's what you said be really thankful for
your cancer because what a gift we've been given all right well we will close out today's meeting
it'll be posted up on Facebook uh for those who weren't able to attend thank you guys again
I'm praying for you daily love you all and um keep up the good work and keep fighting the good fight
thank you thank you so much all right bye bye don't love you as well bye bye